but this is my favorite thing or one of
my favorite things I've seen in the
quarantine that's happened this is a
photo of you it's Tiger king and it's my
favorite because it just says so much
about you as a human as well like you're
so there for the joke whose idea was
this was it yours well you're right I do
I do like to find the fun and things I
do enjoy giving people some light in in
their lives and like everybody I was
obsessed with Tiger King and in like
every actor I was like that's the part
of a lifetime
every once in a while they let me out of
my leading man jail yeah I get to do
like behind the candelabra or like the
drew Peterson's story and I thought
maybe this is the next thing so my wife
Cheryl um before she was a successful
jewelry designer she was like the one of
the leading makeup artists in the movie
business when we met all of that is this
beautiful on the spot sort of prosthetic
makeup the job yeah and that's why it
looks so particularly great and then I
substituted my my little dog Bella for
the tiger and awesome subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going